cinéma le réalisateur de l'esquivé
d'abdellatif kechiche a choisi le thème
de la solidarité autour du père pour son
dernier film la graine et le mulet sous
ce titre se cache le nom d'un plat
tunisiens qui rassemble toute la famille
marie-jo jouant olivier robert ont
rencontré l'équipe du film au dernier
festival de venise
il ne savait pas encore que la graine et
le mulet recevait le prix spécial du
jury et la jeune assia le prix de la
meilleure jeune actrice
la plupart ne sont pas des acteurs
professionnels l'homme qui joue le père
et lui même ouvrier du bâtiment
ça fait 35 ans que je travaille donc en
a marre et le chantier comme le héros du
film qui rêve d'ouvrir son propre
restaurant sur une vieille péniche du
bord de cette histoire de léguer quelque
chose à ses enfants sa patrie mais 35
ans pour sa famille j'avais envie en
racontant cette histoire de donner une
dimension romanesque à cette famille à
ces gens que ce ni même un vrai ouvert
un restaurant sur un vieux bateau et de
lui rouler dessus
vous avez dit j'ai tenu un restaurant
j'avais le premier vous l'avez pas et
pour les frais de fonctionnement de
toute façon on veut du moment que c'est
pas une mosquée y avait dans les
chantiers à réduire alors fait de moi
aussi ça y va
ces restes
mais s'en fout que je fais nous pas il
s'en fout pas et m'a demandé tout à
l'heure ça allait venir mais ce qu'ils
le père dans le film a une maîtresse est
la fille de celle-ci qui va l'aider dans
son projet et quand on demande à la
jeune actrice qui l'a touchée dans son
personnage
et la salle d'analysé du personnage le
naturel du personnage voilà un film
chaleureux exemplaire où la solidarité
d'une famille fait voler en éclats les
clichés sur l'intégration